[Music]
they have these classic debates in
sports right you know uh and you know
who would win athletes from a different
era competed with each other somehow
well there's been a lot of talk about
which team is better the 2012 dream team
or the original 1992
dream team and it's a big debate and of
course it's one of those debates no one
can really answer right okay well
there's one question we can answer and
that's who would win in a basketball
game between andy and i and the 2032
olympic dream team
yes right right we settled this
yesterday and it was such a big deal it
even got coverage on espn check it out
sportsnation let's talk about today's
big game no not the 2012 dream team
versus australia i'm talking of course
about the 2032 dream team versus basic
cables conan o'brien and andy richter it
was more than a little disturbing let's
go to the highlights in burbank where
they spared all sorts of expenses less
than a throwback crowd and the visuals
here there are size disparities
team coco wins the tip off let's see how
they'll do in the early goings oh
richter with the ball the pass to
o'brien the easy bank well richter's
always been incredibly unselfish and
conan's a bit of a ball hog oh great on
defense coast to coast
i don't know what this offensive
strategy is must be something we've
never seen before this to me is the ball
game basically kids half the size of
team coco
now they're they're resting are they
resting against the pads
it's
when the other team even unguarded can't
score
and this is what conan does he attacks
the 10. oh he's an aggressive rim player
i mean he's clearly dominating the glass
we go to the second quarter and uh this
is andy richter's shot banker from about
12 where he doesn't have to move much
he's lived on this for years
this is a spectacular show folks maria
the nanny read the three little pigs to
the boys and the men there he is should
we let the wolf in no don't let it down
don't let him knock down and it worked
perfectly because the kids fell asleep
so then team comes on a nine nothing run
and put this baby away moving at such a
great speed you have to take any
advantage you can when you are playing
at this level you know that's why they
scheduled this game about one o'clock in
the afternoon kids were shot strategic
planning to the fourth quarter now and
oh the kids looked rejuvenated
[Applause]
well i mean listen they were trying to
hold on for their lives here they led by
three points they got very tight one of
the kids right now is crying he's over
the top very upset but o'brien again
with a nice layup
wow dominating
conan attacks the ten as well as getting
late night hope our mindset going in
was
sort of focus on the fact that
that we're growing adults
and they're very small children we knew
we didn't even have to be very good at
basketball
when we come back uh we will switch
gears and talk about real sporting
events played by real men who actually
have self-esteem
it was
[Applause]